jetzt ist das geheimnis gelüftet wir
wissen alle wie es aussieht das neue
iphone 12 schlank schick kantiger und
einer konnte das schon ausprobieren erst
bei mir im studio sven stein
du hast ja auch schon mitgebracht ich
glaube du bist heute der heißbegehrte
man hier irgendwie mit den neuen geräten
ist absurd da hatte ich muss auch ein
bisschen gucken ob sie gar nicht gesehen
hast du einen unterschied erkennen
ehrlich gesagt nicht man sieht den
unterschied auch nur von der rückseite
habt ihr das iphone 12 mit zwei kameras
und das iphone 12 pro mit drei kameras
und einem zusätzlichen sensor von vorne
beide mit 6,1 zoll touchscreen dadurch
sehen sie total ähnlich aus und sind von
vorne nichts unterstellen aber
korrigieren ich glaube es nicht vorher
so dass das iphone pro immer größer war
und jetzt unser service packs glaube ich
nach exakt gemäß gaap eine max version
des iphone pro genau und die ist größer
die wird es ja auch von dem iphone 12
geben die kommt aber erst im november
auf dem markt deswegen reden wir jetzt
erstmal über die beiden 6,1 zoll
varianten was sagst du wenn du hast ja
schon ausprobiert was ist dein eindruck
vom iphone 12 mein eindruck ist apple
hat hier sicherlich sicherlich nicht das
iphone neu erfunden aber es steckt halt
ganz viele wichtige und teilweise auch
überfällige neuheiten drin neue
mobilfunk neues mobilfunksystemen
schnellere prozessor verbesserte kamera
und das alles zusammengenommen bringt
natürlich schon einen großen
leistungssprung
und was kann es jetzt so viel mehr als
das alte hatte ich irgendwas persönlich
überrascht und überzeugt also zunächst
mal muss man natürlich sagen das
wichtigste was ist jetzt kann und das
war wirklich dringend nötig ist die 5g
mobilfunkverbindung also die beide oder
alle vier modelle die dann in den markt
kommen können daten über das neue 5g
mobilfunknetz laden
das können andere hersteller oder bieten
andere hersteller teilweise schon seit
fast einem jahr an
und es war ganz dringend nötig dass das
also jetzt auch in die die iphones kommt
und ansonsten fand ich persönlich zum
beispiel sehr lustig die neue funktion
magsafe dass ich auch schon viel darüber
gesprochen worden ich habe hier immer so
ein ladegerät mitgebracht das man halt
an der steckdose anschließen und das
wird dann einfach magnetisch hinten am
iphone angeschlossen und man kann also
dass diese diese ladeschale zum beispiel
dann auf dem nachttisch
haben und zieht das gerät morgens wieder
ab da kann man auch sich vorstellen dass
der andere zubehör in zukunft kommen
werden es gibt auch hüllen dazu die man
da drauf setzen kann
da denke ich wird richtig noch mal so
eine neue zugehör familie aufgemacht so
wie das früher schon manchmal bei apple
erlebt haben und persönlich überrascht
hat mich wie angetan die leute alle sind
von dem designer anführungsstrichen
alten genau aber aber er hat jetzt
wieder neuen design also dieses kantige
dass wir vom ja seit 2010 vom iphone 4
kennen
aber ich habe in den letzten tagen von
ganz vielen apple nutzern und fans
gehört wie toll dass das ist dass es
zurückkommt und ich muss auch sagen dass
fühlt sich wieder ganz anders an als die
vorgängermodelle aus den letzten jahren
total griffig und sehr stabil und
hochwertig
was ist dein gesamtfazit ist eine
kaufempfehlung braucht mal unbedingt das
neue iphone 12 oder tut auch noch das
letzte modell
wenn ich jetzt ein iphone 11 1 11 promax
da muss ich jetzt nicht zwingend
aktualisieren natürlich das ist ein ist
es ein toller schritt dann 5g zu haben
aber vielleicht will man da noch mal ein
jahr oder zwei abwarten aber wäre jetzt
ein iphone hat das so zwei drei oder
noch mehr jahre alt ist der macht
natürlich ein riesenschritt damit für
den es auf jeden fall eine
kaufempfehlung und wenn man aus der
android welt kommt hat man natürlich
jetzt auch ein paar gute argumente
vielleicht doch richtung apple zu
schauen denn hier gibt es ist auch 5g
ein paar kleinigkeiten die man dort
kriegt fehlen vielleicht noch aber im
großen und ganzen hat apple hier glaube
ich ein wichtiges update gemacht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schau dich je das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren